I think it's fair to say that the Greek
deities are fairly renowned for their
punishments of mortals and gods alike
and so today we'll be taking a look at
the punishments of Tantalus and Sisyphus
Tantalus was the son of Zeus and the
nymph Pluto but being a son of Zeus
certainly doesn't make you immune to
punishment
especially when you anger the gods as
many times as he did as a son of Zeus
and in some cases a respect in the king
he was regularly invited to feasts of
the gods on Mount Olympus but to say
that he was less than a gracious guest
is quite the understatement he would
often get extremely drunk and steal the
gods and nectar and ambrosia the two
drinks that were considered sacred he
then took these back and gave them to
the people of his kingdom to make them
immortal and if that wasn't enough he
then further divulged some of the God's
divine secrets that he had learnt to
asked on Olympus Tantalus then decided
to kill pelops
the future king of the Peloponnese who
also happened to be his son but then
just like the story of king like owen he
chopped his son into pieces and served
him to the gods in a shoe now we know
from King Micah in a story that human
sacrifice was considered a big taboo
amongst the Greek deities and the only
day inti to eat this Jew was Demeter who
at the time was far more concerned about
her missing daughter
the Mariah who were also known as the
three fates then collected the boy's
remaining body pants and gave them to
zeus ordering him to bring the boy back
to life because he was destined to do
great things
the boy would then be put back together
and he's missing a shoulder that was
consumed by Demeter was replace of one
made of ivory constructed by Hephaestus
as punishment phase actions
Tantalus was placed in a pool of water
beneath a fruit tree but whenever
Tantalus reached for the fruit the
branches would raise themselves just
enough so he could never fulfill his
hunger whenever Tantalus wished to
quench his thirst he merely had to stoop
down and drink from the water that he
stood in but every time that he did bend
over to get a drink the water would then
recede leaving him forever thirsty and
forever hungry
there was also an enormous boulder
placed just above his head leaving
Tantalus constantly paranoid that it
could fall at any moment and crush him
this punishment was seen as an example
of temptation without any satisfaction
which is where we get the word
tantalized from which of course refers
to the temptation or the promise of
something that is unattainable in a
slightly different version of this story
Tantalus was given the same punishment
but this time it was for stealing a dog
made of gold created by Hephaestus now
in some accounts it was Tantalus his
friend panderers who actually stole the
dog and gave it to him for safekeeping
and in others the roles were reversed
regardless of who exactly stole the
golden dog it would be Tantalus who
would have to face the punishment the
next punishment is that of King Sisyphus
who was sentenced to an eternity in
Tartarus after revealing the secrets of
Zeus Zeus in his anger then ordered
Thanatos to personally escort the king
to Tartarus and when Thanatos eventually
arrived he brought with him a set of
enchanted chains King Sisyphus desperate
to avoid his punishment then Austin Otis
if he could see how these chains worked
and seeing how he was condemned to an
eternity in Tartarus
Thanatos granted his request but
Sisyphus then took the opportunity to
trick Thanatos and instead bind him in
his own chains and then flee with
Thanatos now bound and unable to perform
his duties no one on earth could die
which caused quite a few issues
especially with the God Ares who could
no longer enjoy the thrill of war as
none of his enemies would die
Ares would eventually intervene free and
Thanatos and bring him back hang
Sisyphus even when Sisyphus finally
entered the underworld it seemed like he
already had an escape plan set in motion
before dying he ordered his wife to
prove her love by throwing his naked
body in the public square
when he arrived in the underworld he
convinced Persephone that what his wife
had done was a grave sign of disrespect
and so after some persuasion she allowed
him to return to the land of the living
to give his body a proper burial of
course once back in his kingdom he had
no intention of ever returning to the
land of the dead when it would take
hermes physically dragging him back to
the underworld for him to finally face
his punishment because of his trickery
and his inability to accept his initial
punishment Sisyphus was made to roll a
huge boulder up what seemed like a steep
hill that would never end as punishment
for thinking he could outsmart Zeus and
the other deities Zeus enchanted the
boulder so it would roll away from
Sisyphus just before he reached the very
top making it so the king was sentenced
to an eternity of useless efforts and
unending frustration this would then
lead to the term Sisyphean which refer
to activities that were either endless
or completely pointless there are many
examples of mortals or gods being
punished with in Greek mythology but
these two stories are often linked
because they both featured Kings who
thought they could outsmart the gods by
sharing their secrets their punishments
both also involved a giant boulder and
their stories and names would be the
source for words in the English language
that we still use today let me know in
the comments below if you've ever heard
of any of these punishments or which one
you think was worse as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained reminding you the importance
of keeping a secret unless you want a
giant boulder dropped on your head
[Music]